[موسيقى]
أجنبية
فعلت شيئًا غير عادي حقًا
لعائلتي ، لكنها رحبت بهم هنا
كمهاجرين قبل سنوات وسمحت لهم
ببناء حياة أفضل
أجنبية
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
أجنبي
لقد جربتها بنفسي
لذلك أريد  لأكون واضحًا معكم جميعًا ، لا
يوجد أي شيء عنصري على الإطلاق في
رغبتك في أن يكون لبريطانيا حدود
آمنة تعمل
[موسيقى] ،
شكرًا لك
[موسيقى]
أجنبي ،
نحن نضع مخططًا جديدًا للاحتفاظ بالوظائف بسبب فيروس كورونا ،
أي صاحب عمل في الدولة صغير أو
كبير للأعمال الخيرية  أو غير هادفة للربح ستكون
مؤهلة للمخطط الأجنبي
[موسيقى]
علينا التحدث عن الهجرة ،
فلنكن صادقين أن نظامنا معطل ،
فنحن لا نسيطر على حدودنا
كل عام ، يأتي الآلاف والآلاف من
الأشخاص إلى المملكة المتحدة بشكل غير قانوني في
كثير من الأحيان.  لا أعرف من هم من أين
أتوا ولماذا هم
هنا ليسوا أشخاصًا سيئين ،
لكن هذا يجعل نظامنا يسخر من نظامنا
ويجب أن يتوقف
[الموسيقى]